[Musique]
un an est passé depuis que l'amérique et
le monde ont découvert stupéfaits à la
télévision les événements du capitole
la profanation du sanctuaire de la
démocratie américaine avait alors dit
joe boyd
depuis les touristes ont réinvesti les
lieux et les élus du congrès ont repris
leurs travaux parlementaires hélène lui
ria est élue démocrate de virginie
colemyn
coville oblige
sept membres de la commission d' enquête
sur le 6 janvier ne reçoit plus qu'en
vidéo
c'était vraiment un événement effrayant
nous étions face à un danger réel mais
c'est tout aussi effrayant d'y penser
rétrospectivement car nous avons assisté
une volonté d'interrompre notre
processus démocratique
une tentative de coup d'état qui dieu
merci a échoué
aujourd'hui la commission d' enquête
parlementaire soit le 6 janvier travail
à comprendre ce qui s'est réellement
passé ce jour là il est essentiel de
savoir ce qui a conduit à une telle
situation et que nous fassions les
récommandations qui empêcheront que cela
ne se reproduise à l'avenir
à washington donc l'inquiétude demeure
mais pour comprendre les mécanismes qui
ont conduit aussi l'envié il faut
quitter la capitale direction la
pennsylvanie et la petite ville de
jonestown
jaqee que le bac est élue républicaine
du comté c'est elle il y a un an qui a
organisé le voyage de ces militants vers
la capitale deux bus qui transportait un
peu plus d'une centaine de trump heist
convaincu
pour cet élu comme pour une majorité de
républicains l'attak du capitole est
indéfendable mais les torts serait
néanmoins partager
les gars qui sont allés jusqu'à là bas
il y serait allé coûte que coûte au
moins je m'étais dit que si quelque
chose devait tourner mal je pourrais
rassembler tout le monde et les
rassembler vers le bus pour les ramener
en sécurité à la maison
bien sûr que j'ai vu des gens qui
rentraient dans le capitole comment
voulez vous ne pas voir un homme avec un
casque à cornes et torse nu au beau
milieu du mois de janvier
une simple manifestation pacifiste qui
aurait mal tourné
le groupe de jonestown avait quitté les
lieux bien avant de pouvoir s'en rendre
compte
quand on a vu tout ça j'étais choquée et
confuse
mais ce que je n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi il
n'y avait pas de forces de sécurité
on a vu nulle part
quand on a enfin vu arriver la police du
capitole c'était déjà le milieu de
l'après-midi
à jonestown nous n'avons trouvé personne
qui reconnaissent être entré dans le
capital ce jour là et pour cause près de
700 manifestants ont été arrêtés et
poursuivis pour ce crime fédéral
parmi eux 15 % d'anciens combattants
américains parfois même soupçonné
d'avoir dirigé l'attaqué
j'aurais pu y être juste pour montrer
mon soutien à cette cause et cette cause
c'est tout simplement la frustration or
la clé de cette frustration c'est que
beaucoup de gens ne croyaient pas que
monsieur joe biden avait gagné il
pensait que trump l'avait emporté et que
les chiffres avaient été trafiqués je
n'approuve pas ce qui s'est passé mais
je comprends pourquoi c'est arrivé
absolument aucun de ces trois hommes n'a
jamais réellement cessé d'être un solde
mais des soldats libérés de leur devoir
de réserve et qui dans une certaine
mesure
son la voix de quelques grands corps de
l'état comme l'armée
ici à cette table on a tous fait la
guerre
on connaît le prix à payer pour pouvoir
vivre dans une démocratie
or nous disposons de quelque chose que
les autres pays n'ont pas nous pouvons
nous débarrasser de notre gouvernement
si c'est ce que l'on veut ça peut être
fait
d'abord légalement par le vote bien sûr
mais ensuite il y à notre deuxième
amendement beaucoup de gens pensent que
ce deuxième amendement n'est qu'une
histoire de chasseurs et d'armes à feu
mais ce n'est pas le cas d'ailleurs
quand cet amendement a été rédigée le
peuple n'avait pas encore le droit de
posséder des armes
par contre qu'il dit clairement c'est
chaque citoyen droit de se défendre
contre un gouvernement tyrannique
nous sommes en train de perdre notre
grandeur nos politiciens ne sont plus là
pour s'occuper de leur communauté ou de
ceux qui les ont élus ils sont là parce
qu'ils aiment leur mode de vie
johnston ressemble à cette amérique trop
loin de washington pour être entendu un
an après les événements du 6 janvier et
même si ses électeurs américains ne sont
plus représentés à la maison blanche le
ressentiment lui reste intacte